now that i'm in it it just makes me so
excited because there's been so many
influences to like steer me away from
being
where i'm at right now like my parents
don't agree with it at all
i get called a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and i
get told that i'm gonna be like
on crack by the time i get here and it's
so hard because like
these are my parents telling me these
things and all my friends are really
supportive they're like
as long as you're safe as long as it's
everything good and you're happy that's
all i want and i'm like
okay raven yes raven oh where'd you grow
up where are you from originally i grew
up in a small town
of four thousand um in sacramento area
it's uh one like an hour away from tahoe
so just completely
nature and surrounded by trees and i've
lived there my whole life and just kind
of move around the area just never left
it
okay and tell me about your your family
you had both your parents when you were
young
yes i had both my parents but they were
not really together i want to say for a
long time in my life just
because they would argue and they would
fight then they would break up and get
back together
and break up and get back together and i
would stay with my grandparents which
were
more like my parents and like my uncles
and my aunts since i would just be with
like surrounded by them 24 7.
and that's where they got married around
like 2008 but still had like those
arguments so
they are together just not stably
so what was the reason you you were
raised mostly by your grandparents
um my parents uh started out as
alcoholics and they got
a little tangled in drugs uh um right
right when i was born like my mother had
just stopped alcohol when she found out
she was pregnant
with me like she just quit drugs when i
like she found out that she was pregnant
and sort of had me with a trauma bond
instead of like really bonding with me
and after i was born she did take care
of me but then she just started working
she started drinking again and my eldest
sister and my second eldest sister
became sort of my parents as well when
they were home from school or
staying home from school so how would
you describe your childhood
eventful very eventful and
very traumatic that's a good one but
it's very eventful there's a lot
there's lots of really good moments but
they're just weighed down by
everything else like i got diagnosed
with cptsd which is a complex
post-traumatic stress disorder just
because every single year of my life
i've
never not had something traumatic like
either every month or like every other
month
so i've just gotten so like desensitized
to a lot of traumatic things and i've
like
grown to pain but it was very eventful
at least for
me and i don't know about like my other
siblings but i know we can like talk
about it a little bit and like share
traumas and know that we're not like
crazy
what kind of trauma what kind of things
did you go through um
one my sister went through when i was
one that she told me
that we just actually bonded over is
like my mom was on a drunken rage i was
one years old
she had me in um her arms in the
bathroom barricading it because my
own mom wanted to attack me and her and
i was only one
um other instances are like my parents
would just get so drunk
and just like get to the point where
you're angry you're irritable you're
puking
and like you should go to bed but they
would stay up and just start arguments
we'd have to have the cops called
so many times for domestic abuse and
it's like
um i'd have to go to my nana's which
would be
like everything but one night for me
specifically
that i just like distinctly remember is
i was like two or three
maybe like four at the max and my mom
and dad got into a huge fight it wasn't
even like dark out yet
it was about like five six in the summer
and she was
drunk and crying in her bat in her back
room
and there were guns back there and i had
police officers actually like use me
as bait to get her out because she was
threatening to kill herself
and like at the time like i was like oh
my gosh my mom's gonna hurt herself i
need to save her and like that's
like a three-year-old would think
because i didn't really like think past
it
and she like i had to be bait i had cops
behind me waiting
and like just in case they had like guns
ready if she were trying to shoot me
i had no clue and i finally got her out
and then i put her in handcuffs and like
by that age i was like i arrested my mom
and i was like that was just such like a
traumatic change for me and like at
least in school like before i even went
into full school
there was just such this like different
person by the time i got there
so it's like i used to be this like
really fun bubbly energetic kid and then
by like age five i was already
independent i just wanted to go to
school go home and sleep
or at least like play with toys and
dissociate from
whatever is going on that's a lot to go
through
so no sexual abuse or anything like that
unfortunately i did go through sexual
abuse
um i've gone through a lot of therapy
and i've just actually been
open to getting it and willing to at
least just because i've had so many
eventful things and like
going after therapy is so good therapy
is great i always promote it but it is
heavy when
you realize like parts of your trauma
hood that you couldn't really remember
before
and now like you're remembering them uh
my uncle
when i was younger um would always i was
so into like technology and games he
would show me like his game boys all
gamecube and everything and then the
computer and one day i happened to just
see like a
lewd picture of like an anime girl who
had like bigger breasts and like she's
wearing something skimpy and cute
and i didn't think anything of it
because it was like whoa that's kind of
like pokemon or something like that and
i was really heavily into
japanese cartoons so i was really
interested but
one day i just remember watching
like anime porn and i didn't know that
hentai i was watching it
and i didn't know that what he was doing
was teaching me to masturbate and he was
touching me
and like it was so much just to like
have in my
head and going whoa is this why i'm like
hypersexual this is why i'm like anime
and it was like a real life changer for
me
and i was like do i like any of these
things because
like i just got traumatized and that
like really took a toll on me because i
just started the industry and i was just
here
and i was like wow it's like my whole
life a lie but
it really like made me who i was but
it did shape who i was because after
that it was different we
had incidents at school with me where i
just would let people touch me and do
whatever
and when it came down to it to like who
taught you this i couldn't really say my
uncle and i didn't
know how to do it so i just blamed
myself like i said i looked it up online
yeah how are you in this uh at least
five or six
i was kindergarten or first grade so
and that's where like another part of me
somebody just said like
at least my nana said like a light in me
just like died
and for years and years she would always
say you know i think he touched you
and me being me i would just deny it
until i went through specific therapy
and it's like it was such a game changer
for me but
it helped me get over a lot of things
because i was hypersexual and i would
let
like boyfriends abuse me and sexually
like abuse me and almost rape me
because i thought that was okay and
actually coming into the industry i've
learned
so many standards people wouldn't think
like there's so many like standards and
safety and consent that comes with this
industry that
the fantasy may like portray differently
but it is nothing
compared to what i've actually been
through and then compared to like doing
a scene where they're like oh are you
okay compared to somebody
not caring what they do in the real
world oh yeah they just don't care
they're like i didn't do it and you're
like
i saw you do it and it's a straight face
whereas in the porn industry you're
protected
oh yeah it's like i even say like al
like pretending and they're like wait
stop
are you okay and i'm like wow this is so
much different than like
what people perceive it to be and what i
perceived it
at least growing up but i got the worst
end of it in the actual like fantasy
people want
so after so you went through high school
yeah i actually made it through high
school um it was really rough
for four years i at least like i went to
el dorado high school
and that school is very
harsh as it is it's known like to be a
druggie school where all the stoners
kids go and all the depressed kids and
el dorado county has like just kind of a
bad rep
at least when i was going there there
was a lot of drug abuse a lot of
like stds were going around too because
we weren't actually
properly educated there was pregnancies
and like we even found
like needles in the bathroom at one
point my sophomore year i think
but i was no better because i had like
pills fed to me
um my mother would give me norcos or
tylenol threes and even percocets like
oxycodone
i was like pain relief for like my
headaches or something instead of just
going to like a neurologist
that costs 300 we would just get pills
for like
two bucks do you think you were addicted
oh i was definitely addicted it was such
a good feeling just to like escape
reality
i still did my homework like i still
managed to like
um just be dependent for a while for
like two years like i was obviously
addicted because
i would be cranky and i'd detox and
withdraw if i didn't have them
but i at least managed to get
my studies and my focus done and i made
sure to learn something at least while
i'm just messed up
and by the time i like started like
experimenting with weed like my friend
was like here try this i didn't even
want to do pills anymore
i was like whoa i was like this makes me
feel better and i don't even want to
take it anymore i was like what is this
and then i like would have like family
issues because pills are prescribed and
safer
than like marijuana which was getting
legalized at the time and was like
almost fully legalized
and it was just so hard because
at like age 14 i had norcos and like at
age 14 my friends were just starting
with like weed or not even like
thinking about drugs maybe like vaping
at the most
but my generation at least my like class
was very traumatized i at least knew the
people from my middle school were
traumatized we were
bullied beat up by our like eighth
graders all the time
and like the school really didn't do a
lot about it until we were gonna leave
and we had like anti-bullying talks and
like
if we're having a rough time at home
call someone and like
going into high school knowing that
information we still like managed to get
addicted to drugs and
instead of telling each other it's wrong
we already knew what a bunch of
each other we're going through and i did
theater for four years it was the best
experience of my life
i got to do things like this in like
one-on-ones with like people
i would never really talk to somebody
who has like a
upperclassman that's so popular has the
same life as me
and it's like it was such a good
experience and i love studio 81
if i could donate so much money to them
i would right now
but like just like wait get a savings
that place really did save me a lot
because there was so many people that
were like me but
so different and hid it just as well as
me but i had that shame of abuse because
i didn't really know it was abuse
until i think i was like a senior and i
was sleeping through most of my classes
and i even got kicked out
um well taken from my home because i had
to call the cops on my mom
and still go to school the next day like
like the same day go to school and it
was so funny
because she was attacking me because i
wanted to leave it was getting too much
i wanted to go to rehab and get myself
clean and just get away from her because
she was physically attacking me
and so when i actually like called the
cops got out of the house i started
detoxing
learning about other people who's got it
way worse than me
but like still is in the same area as me
and i got to actually learn like what my
problems were how to get out
but i got sidetracked by like raving
which i got to be med tent but i also
fell into all the drugs that like raves
do
enable you to have and they're right
there but
once i started like uh messing with
psychedelics i was like this is a
problem because you do get in your head
and i was like
my body is skinny i'm losing weight not
gaining it
um pills are a problem and
december 24th of 2019 i just gave gave
pills up cold turkey
went through the whole detox went
through everything and i was like i
don't want to end up
where my mom is and it's she has four
girls
and all of them are kind of questioning
why they like
how they messed up so much when
we didn't really do anything wrong we're
a child we're here just to learn
and we had to like teach and learn
ourselves
so you're clean now oh yeah i'm clean
100
i have like on my phone these calendar
like these clocks of days of everything
that i stopped using what days and
there's nothing under
100 right now or even 170.
and i'm so excited about that because
it's such like a hard thing to talk
about is the shame of drug abuse
and it's like somebody like me like they
could probably see me as a stoner yeah
that's
that's i give off those vibes a hundred
percent but
no one knew that i was abusing narcos
and even percocets no one really knew
that my friend was doing like lines like
she was snorting xanax and she was doing
lines like this
and i would cut it in half because she
would overdose
and it was really hard because i had to
like give up a whole friendship and
friend group
to get sober and to like even help my
friend get sober because she was doing
lines of coke
and like i almost overdosed in her house
just from like half a line she was doing
and she was doing more than me and i
didn't even do coke i was doing her
xanax lines
so i was like oh my gosh i was like i
can't do it and
i even lost that friendship but it's
like
the whole like drugs are just they
affect you so differently and the shame
just
you never actually reach out until you
hit rock bottom
but i've gone to n a meetings they've
actually really saved a lot of like
they've wasted so much of my time
sometimes but it just
gives me another reason to like want to
help people who are in those situations
like on my twitter i may have like a
thousand followers
already but i'll still message people
back i've had people say hey
i'm having uh suicide problems i'm like
i i don't care raven is here i'm still
talking to you right here but if you
want my personal information i'm here
just because i know how hard it is not
to have anyone
especially like i had my nana and my mom
but
my nana would tell me straight and she
passed away
this last june or no july this last july
of 2020
so i haven't really had her to like help
keep me going or like my mom
but i my mom was my enabler as well and
like basically
my supplier to all my drugs and it was
really hard when i stopped doing them
because they're right there i could
still do them they she has them in the
house but it's like
i'm still using today um she uses
suboxone which is a lower form
of opioid but to be honest she really
does stockpile them and doesn't use them
or she'll
overuse one day because she's in more
pain and i'm like that's just the
addiction
because you don't really need all these
boxes of drugs for possible future
outcomes that's just like the shame you
have
and we get into massive arguments over
it because she says
that she's clean she's doing fine but
you're not clean if you're still using
it and making excuses and it's so hard
because i know like my mom and i will
never have that relationship that i
really envy that everyone has like i'll
see tick tocks
of people with their moms and i'm like
man if i did tick tocks people would be
really depressed and i'd go viral for
another reason
and it's like i do have to like record
my mom's arguments in mine because
she does invalidate all my
experiences i've had and i wouldn't be
where i was like where i am now if i
didn't have them
and like everyone who like has those
relationships
at least even if they are drugged ones
and like they have like close
relationships with their family i really
envy that
just because i've like i had that with
both of my grandmothers and now they're
gone
and it's like so hard because people are
like i've lost my mother i'm like
me too but my biological one's still
alive and it's hard because people don't
understand that but
my eldest sister and i like have talked
about it and it's got
like we agree that we lost our mom a
long time ago
and like she's still trying to find
herself but
we can't really help her with that and
that's like the hardest part
about at least like me is because
everyone's like oh go talk to your mom
or this and i'm like
okay shane's a big part of addiction it
is um
i was i didn't go to my mom like even
though like she was the one giving
it to me um i would go to my nana she
was the only person that had no shame on
it but i never really went to my friends
for help until
i was like skinny i wasn't eating i
wasn't
hungry i was detoxing completely i lost
like 10 pounds
and it just completely like changed me
and i was so shameful just to tell
people yeah i'm detoxing from drugs
until one day i just got so fed up
with people expecting me to help them
and be in their lives and i'm like i'm
trying to like get my [ __ ] together
myself
and i'm like what i'm like what am i
supposed to do so
i just told people i'm like hey i'm
going through this problem right now i'm
addicted to
like pills and i i can't help anyone
until i help myself
and it was at that moment that i lost so
many people
so many people just stopped being my
friend they were like oh you're no fun
you're prude i'm like yeah i am
i'll take it i'm a prude but um
i even i got closer with so many other
people who are like i actually want to
quit too and i'm having a struggle
and that's when i got like this really
good group of friends that i just
acquired and i'm working hard to keep um
just because it's a lot of work and when
i was
on drugs i just didn't care if i had
friends i would talk to them like they
were my best friends
ever but in reality we had no clue about
each other and
getting over that shame really brought
the real people the genuine friends that
i have
out and it just takes that like big step
of getting over your own fears and
boundaries
just because you're your own worst enemy
during those times
[Music]
so then at some point you got it how old
are you i'm only 20.
you're 20. so you've been through a lot
for a 20 year old oh yeah
and then you got into porn at some at
some point i got into porn when i was
19.
um last year actually i was for the
pandemic when that started
um i got kicked out because my mom
listened to a conversation
and uh she um
listened to like me talking about my
past drug use
and me talking to someone privately just
about like
help and i was getting off the shame she
kicked me out
dramatically and like very traumatically
and
that is when i actually like started
getting things together but then it was
a pandemic
so there was not a lot of things open
everything was going down
and i said you know what i've been
saying this since i was young like if i
have no other option why not be a
stripper or porn star and i was just
joking
but i was serious at that point i was
like you know what i'm really hyper
sexual
i take like pride in actually pleasing
someone
i've had an only fans for a little bit
and i'm comfortable with it
i was like you know what i'm gonna try
it and so i just went on to like pornhub
out of everything and i noticed there's
like want to join the talent sign here
and i clicked on one of them and um
in april i got just like a call back
from like back room casting couch
and that's when they were like we would
love to have you
and i was just so shook that somebody
was like yeah your pictures that you
sent in were beautiful
and i was like you know what it's two
thousand dollars
i didn't get a stimulus i was a student
i was like i need this money just to
live
i was like it'll help me out like it's a
one time thing no contract sign i was
like and if i like it i like it if i
don't
never again and it ended up being such
an amazing thing they paid for like my
flights and everything which
usually doesn't happen but it was just
such an amazing experience and just to
get like money for actually doing work
and helping out and being genuine
i was like this is so amazing and during
the pandemic it just
it helped out so much because i didn't
have my parents um
i applied for like loans and like i
couldn't even get loans or grants i was
working three jobs
and it was just right when um
i did that i was like you know this
might be something and
i didn't think anything of it i kind of
let my ego get to it a little bit but
then i got a call
a week later from the same people and
they're like hey we had someone cancel
would you like to do another shoot this
is like a one-time thing we don't
usually offer this and i was like yes
let me take it
i didn't even care about the offer i
didn't even care i was like i will be
there asap
i go on a plane the next morning and it
was i was like this is something that i
want to do
i like traveling i like having to
actually keep a good image on my body
and work
harder for what i want because yeah i
could pay for someone to make me
beautiful but like
working hard for it and like having
people be like you are genuinely
beautiful and like hear it all the time
at least in the industry really like
gave me the confidence i need
needed and after my nana died like a few
months later i was like
i fell into a depression work-wise it
was even worse for kovid
and that's when i just get a call or and
um they're like do you want to actually
be in the industry
it's calming down we can get you in and
do shoots and i went yes
without a hesitation i started working
up just to drive down to la
and i actually ended up flying and it
just became such a good
experience for me just because i got to
like witness what it would actually be
like and see if i could
actually handle it and at first it was
really scary
just to have like all these cameras on
me all these people looking at me
telling me how to pose telling you how
to look and
not even knowing what like pictures
would come out and having just like this
little insecurity that
i've had for so long and
it just all washed away and now that i'm
in it it just makes me so excited
because there's been so many influences
to like steer me away from being
where i'm at right now like my parents
don't agree with it at all
i get called a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and i
get told that i'm gonna be like
on crack by the time i get here and it's
so hard because like these are my
parents telling me these things
and all my friends are really supportive
they're like as long as you're safe as
long as it's everything good and you're
happy that's all i want and i'm like
i'm happy where i'm at i'm getting
somewhere where i want to be and then
it's like
i let family overshadow like the actual
people that are important
and listening to people that are
important have really gotten me
to where i am today and i'm not hesitant
i'm really excited to wear like i get a
text about a shoe and if i can't make it
just because i'm too far away i just get
so excited
even if it's like lower than anything
even a hundred dollars just to like help
out it's
so much fun and i want to be just dive
in and a part of it
because it's it gives me something more
than what i had a few years ago which
was just
drugs trauma and pain so it's partially
a way to support yourself financially
exactly and then also there's the
hypersexuality you think from
that does that come from what happened
to you i've been
sexually assaulted by many exes um and
like my own family member and like it's
learning like because i was hypersexual
ever since that incident and my parents
never knew why
and i've always wondered why i've had
just such a high sex drive and i've been
so aware and i've been so into it
compared to everyone
my age that this just makes it easy to
at least cope a little bit
but also to get out of the fear
because i know a lot of people who have
been sexually assaulted or sexually
abused
do have that fear whenever they're
really intimate with someone
and i've had like times where i've cried
afterwards after somebody i've like
really genuinely enjoyed and i'm like
why am i crying
and doing this really did help and
it's not like everyone's cup of tea
there's other ways to really like get
out of it but for me this really did
help
get over a lot of like stressors and
anxieties that i've had from past
experiences and with that it really did
help
just kind of grow at least and find out
what i actually do like
and not just to be like having a one
night stand with someone who doesn't
know anything
and they're really drunk compared to
someone who's done this for years
can actually help me find what i like is
really like
sensitive to like me and like i can
actually talk to people about
that in the industry and a lot of people
in the industry
are like can relate to me and it's so
sad but it's
it just makes it even more welcoming and
it gives me standards to what i want
for when i am intimate with someone else
that's not really my work
is there any shame connected with this
there was
there was at first when i did my two
first shoots and i wasn't really with an
agency
there was a lot of shame because i lost
a few people for it
and a lot of people like started fights
over it with me
and i'm like this is my choice my body
unless you want to pay my bills
for me then like by all means but
i've tried to pay all my bills all by
myself i've had help from some people
during covid but everything else i've
really worked hard for
and it's the shame with this part i
think the only shame
was just because i didn't have an agency
and like
like my videos would be there and i
would just not have like make profit or
have anything besides my only fans
but then that's when i got a call from
next level agency i'm like oh my gosh
i was like they're a really good agency
and that's when
i just gave up the shame i was like who
cares if they're not paying my bills
then why should i care
and like they're not living my body they
haven't gone through anything
i would love for them to take a day off
in my shoes for me
so that's like at least with me the
shame was really easy to just drop it
out
because i'm in my like in my natural
body why should i really be ashamed of
that
and then with like how drugs were um
there's just a different shame
and once i got rid of at least the porn
shame the drug shame just
like slipped off with it too to where i
can talk about it openly and be like yep
i'm a recovering addict forever
but at least i'm not an active addict
right now is this the best plan in your
life right now
i am this is the best start because i'm
ending
a lot of traumatic connections with
people and a lot of trauma bonds
this is just like the start to something
like great since i am only 20
and i have no clue what's like to come
for me for these next years but i know
this is just like such an amazing start
an amazing just like push to where i
want to go
just because i know i can't physically
do sex forever
like i'm really into cosmetology film
and photography
and like i've actually been saving up
for school to do that even though it's
so expensive in california
and i've been trying to apply to grants
and everything and still have like
something else to do besides like here
since i do have
like sometimes i have weeks that i don't
get shoots so i'm just like what do i do
during this time
that i can make flexible and it's like
all my hobbies that i like are coming
into one so i can do it
and it's just such an amazing time even
though we're in like still in a pandemic
it's like a really rough harsh time but
it's such a good time to just start
like something new and to grow it since
pretty much a lot of people are at rock
bottom right now
and it's like that's the best thing is
you have a chance to actually like
build something and if it doesn't work
it's okay it's okay you can start over
you're already at rock bottom yeah
tell me about working in porn is it i
mean are you asked to do things
sometimes that you're uncomfortable with
um yes and i can easily always say no to
that
just because it seems like there's a
trend yeah to go towards the most
extreme
sexual things they can come up with
i'm really kinky and i've like i've been
through a lot of abuse so like
someone would be like yeah you have a
bruise and i'd be like i don't even feel
it
and so my pain tolerance is really high
for a lot of things that a lot of people
would be like oh gosh i couldn't get
tied up i'm like i don't care
it's it's not as bad as what i've been
through and so that helps a lot with me
but there have been times where
um there's just been like
miscommunication on what i like
and there's usually like a tap signal or
like a word that we say
and like we just do the scene over again
or i've been offered bookings for things
that i'm not into and i just politely
pass them
just because it's not my cup of tea but
then somebody else from my agency might
get it and do amazing because they love
it
like i know a lot of people are like oh
i'll be gay for pay and i'm like i'm
bisexual
i won't be gay for pay but i won't do
anything that's like out of my comfort
zone just to get paid
i'll work harder somewhere else like on
my only fans or something to make up for
something i missed
just because it's so open and it's
really consensual for this industry
i know a lot of people who've been in
different agencies have like said
otherwise because it's more of like an
escort
and not an actual like professional
agency and it's really it just depends
on the agency the industry itself is
so good but there's a lot of downfalls
to it
it just really depends on where you put
yourself and like if you find all the
facts right
but for me it's it's been the most
consensual thing ever this is the
like best like sex that i've had just
because it's so sa it's the safest sex
i've had
um it's like fantasies i want to do i'm
making
money from it and i'm actually like
learning about myself
so with all of that and like with my
agency i have an amazing agency
it just fits so perfectly but for other
people they may have like
a really bad industry like industry
agency for the industry
and it can like really mess with someone
and i can see where there's some points
where
it's like wow this industry is really
messed up but
it's kind of like the music industry as
well it's harsh
you don't always have to have
connections but if you have like a good
agency to help you it really does
make a day go around so
coming from the childhood that you had
in the struggles that you've had
i mean what what what are your insights
into
coming from a background like that yeah
you have a drug addict mom
you had you had uncles that were
touching you you had
you know very little parental uh
guidance it seemed like other than your
grandmother
oh gosh it's just it's just it's just
for a child to go through that and just
be
turn out the way that i am right now you
seem to be pretty good but
but you're a drug addict and now you're
working in porn and you're 20 years old
and that you
on paper that looks kind of like oh yeah
whenever i think about it and like
just put it out flat without context it
does seem like my life has gone down
spiral and it's been
like it's really hard just because like
when i do tell people i'm a recovering
addict some people react to like hiding
their pills and do it and like being
freaked out
and it does like hurt a little bit but
that's like who i am
and that's like what i did choose
because i was actively taking it from my
mom
and like even though i was a minor and i
didn't have like
like any form of stability or way to
actually like take care of myself until
17 when i started a job
it's just like it's the way you like
treat people to
people don't know me and like some
people treat me really rude because i'm
tiny they think they can like take me
but i'm really
like i i'm such an aggressive person and
no one would think that
but with all those years of abuse and
like you have no idea
what's on the other side when you look
at someone you have no idea what's
behind them you have
no clue what they've gone through and
with me i'm so open about it now
but before i would just take it out on
people if someone would shove me i would
either like cry really hard or i'd shove
them back because
that's what i was taught at home and it
took so many years to get over it
and for people who have no idea what
it's like to go through this
it's just a lot of just mental hate it's
just self-hate
because a lot of my friends hate
themselves because their parents
did like just chose to do things and
it's like i hated myself every year for
like christmas because i would want one
thing maybe like sort of expensive but
in the hundreds
and my parents would go all out and make
me feel so horrible
for wanting something and i know a lot
of people
went through just like taking it in and
internalizing it because that's what
you're supposed to do as children
but when you become like 14 it comes out
and we don't really
like fully realize that since children
don't really need therapy
is they're happy right and that's where
it came in to me at least and looking
back at it i'm like i've had
a roller coaster of a ride like i've
tried to kill myself many of times just
because it mentally is too much and
being untreated for like adhd and cptsd
and so many other things being untreated
it was so much
and without it i i would be such a
different person i'm so grateful i went
through this
and possibly save someone else from not
going through this
because there were so many so many
people that could not handle
where i'm at today and i don't think of
myself as strong because like my arms
are small and i
probably could get beat up by literally
anyone
but i'm such a strong person and like
everyone who
has trauma or abuse or has like
just anything that can relate to me can
understand that
you'll get back up you don't care and
we'll still get back up because we've
been used to it
and it makes you stronger it really does
and people don't realize it
because they just get so like in their
head and they just get so
hateful of like all these things that
they couldn't control and for people
who've never gone through it it's just
such
like it's so nice for me at least to
just see someone like not go through
something
and they're like yeah my life is really
good and i'm like that is amazing i hope
nothing happens to you because it's just
it changes you forever and if you like
know someone who's been sexually
assaulted they
will never be the same person that they
were before
you just have like a part of you taken
out that you have to deal with that you
don't like
and it's just stuck with you forever
and it's hard for people but at least
for me i've learned just to accept it
and that's like the biggest thing oh l.a
but it's just like the biggest thing and
especially in la there's so many people
going through it during covid and it
just
breaks my heart that ever like they may
reach out or they may not
and they have to go through this and not
enough people are aware
of like the signs of people going
through stuff just because
we're so good at hiding it and
as much as i i love people who don't go
through this stuff i just
hate the ignorance that sometimes comes
just of like
don't you have no clue what that person
has gone through and it's been
hell like i've people have threatened to
beat me up and i've gone
my mother can probably do better than
you i'm sorry
like you're nowhere compared to where
this woman or like
anybody any of my exes could be and
for people who just don't go through it
they just i just like
always recommend taking a step back for
some situations and always
thinking before you speak just because
some people really are not there
when they're going through it and it's
so hard to like not project
when you've just gone through something
or not shut down
or go into a depressive episode and it's
like these things are so normal to me
and when my friends go through it
they'll be depressed on the couch i'll
be cleaning their house
and i'll just be taking care of them
because i know it's something that's
normal
and it's like the shame that comes with
it even people like just go through
something never gone through
something in their life gets shameful
that bad things happen to them
and it's not really just it's not really
your fault it's
out of your control unless like you're
an addict taking pills you know it's
your fault you just need the support
and that's what i've been lacking my
whole life is like outside support
because i've just had me
and like now that i have it it's such a
different it's such a difference
like i tried rejecting it at first
because that's what people do
but once you accept it and it's you know
your boundaries and you learn yourself
and how you can like function with
others without
being scared of your past traumas it
really does help people
especially if you've never gone through
it you can see a different change with
someone
once you've resolved or at least like
got some closure to something that's
been bugging them
with what with therapy oh yeah therapy
or even just talking to a friend and
actually having like a real sit-down not
like oh my god that's so funny lmao
whatever
like having a real sit down with people
and just talking like
communicating not with a phone which is
so hard during kovid
and that's why so many other people are
having depression and like families are
arguing
and i've seen so many tick tocks of
people just like yay my mom's abusive
again because i moved back i'm like
i understand it completely and that's
something that i hate that i can
understand
is like i know if i ever have a kid is
that
that's never gonna happen is that
unwanted feeling or that just
fear and that's where a lot of people
can empathize with me is that they don't
respect a lot of people they fear a lot
of people
just because you can't gain fear with
respect what do you think the difference
is between
people who end up broken
from the childhoods like yours and
people like yourself who maybe
have climbed out of it and become
stronger the worst case scenario that
like i've just seen are like serial
killers happen and like if you look at
them they're
way high but like if you look at them as
like the worst case scenario
they've been through troubled childhood
some have not but like a lot of
people who do crimes or even like kill
others
have such emotional like emotions just
like bottled up from like their
emotional abuse and trauma
and i've like looked at so many people
like they wouldn't have done drugs if
they didn't have this
influencer there this stressor and
it's just so much because
it's right then and there and if you
can't reach out because you're shameful
or you don't
know that it's this traumatic for you
you're gonna do something stupid by by
all means or
you're gonna end up like me hopefully or
you're gonna be lost for a while and it
does feel really harsh
to just not really know what you're
doing kind of learning yourself and
that's why i did all of last year
is i would just cry and cry even when i
started here i just cry because
life is so hard but i wasn't reaching
out like i
thought i was until somebody said you
haven't talked to me why didn't you
reach out i'm like oh gosh i was like
because i'm depressed what am i supposed
to do and
once i can like joke about it and get
over it and like even realize what i'm
doing
like transparency with people like at
least i can handle it
because people will be like you're
depressed get out of bed i'll be like oh
you're right
but some people really need that like
support system that i never had or that
i was that person
but never got it back and so with that
it's just there's so many different ways
people could end up
because if you let it prolong and you
don't actually
acknowledge the problems or you don't
cope with it
and your body just one day you get mad
because you can't close a drawer
and you're mad about everything last
past 20 years
like that's like a worst case scenario
for a normal person
but then like there's serial killers or
even people who kill themselves because
it's just
so much and in mental health at least
right now i've noticed is just
not taken seriously anymore because
everyone has depression
everyone has this every everyone's
having problems but it's just because we
have
literally no support system during covid
we're all locked away from each other
and people don't want to be on their
phones as much because that's all we
have is to connect with each other
and i think like this last year and like
still going on is going to be the
hardest
mentally at least because no person
expected a pandemic
no one expected to change their life or
go back to an old life they had
abandoned
like i did and it's
so hard especially since everyone's
going through this nationwide
at least for me i know i have cried
multiple times from it and i've stress
cried just screamed in my car
and like just had moments where i'm like
why
and it's just the support system i think
people need
to like either end up on like a really
like outburst
spectrum of a meltdown or a more calm
burnout
and that's where i think everyone was
this year is just burnt out
too much working too little working it
was just so much stress everyone had to
change their life
for either the best or the worst at the
time and that's all we had to deal with
and it was out of our control
and like at least with me i know that
like i can empathize with people during
kovid because
it is so much and it's so beautiful just
to like
oh gosh with someone i never think that
i would be
sympathizing and empathizing with
actually turn into a really good friend
of mine
and like they may have followers
thousands of followers
and just because i reached out one day
and this one follower just had a feeling
that they were not okay and
now we're friends and it's like wow
we really don't reach out as much as we
do and that's where
the shame just like comes back in and
once you just literally take it off it's
like
it's literally just like a cloak you
just take it off and it's gone
that's why i have like no shame at my
doors no shame in my car no shame
anywhere
you shouldn't have shame for anything
unless you're doing something
like wrong and that's at least what i
felt growing up
and probably how everyone feels as well
all right raven well thank you so much
for sharing your story very interesting
thank you for having me
thank you very much
you